and
i'm in hockey
it's
12 44 pm
and we have aviation strike
for weeks bombs have rained down on the
city of harkiv in northeastern ukraine
russian rockets and deadly cluster bombs
have killed hundreds of civilians in the
city since the invasion began
and emergency crews are still working to
uncover bodies from the rubble
there's fresh blood on the ground when
alexei zavrozni stepped out of his
apartment to investigate the destruction
we just
bomb strike here
so as you can see
a lot of blood
and
just to compare this is this is my leg
uh it's huge bomb
this man witnessed the attack that
killed a woman who was on her way to a
store
[Applause]
two more grand missiles fell in a
children's playground nearby
[Music]
and i personally walked there with my
eight-month-old daughter
and as you can see there is no military
objects except of
this one
harkiv is the second largest city in
ukraine
nearly 1.5 million people called this
place home
but after weeks of relentless shelling
by russian forces the city lies in ruin
its residents desperate to escape
oh
it's close
for eight days alexi and his wife and
young daughter have been hiding out in
their apartment
alright so it's wednesday march 2nd uh 2
28 p.m
and we are packing our stuff we decided
to leave har cave tomorrow morning uh we
will just drive on our car
uh to the central ukraine we have
friends or friends there and we're doing
that
with
you know some sort of
panic but
not a complete panic
and
the only thing that i want is
to make this little sweetheart to never
remember these days
they join hundreds of thousands of
others who have fled the besieged city
as cars line up along the highway to
fill their tanks for the long journey
west
roman tropin drives against the flow of
traffic
he makes the two and a half hour drive
from dinipra to harkiv a few times a
week
carrying with him much needed medical
supplies and food
with most stores and services shuttered
the supplies brought in from out of town
have become a lifeline for people
trapped in arkiv
this school has been turned into an
emergency supply center
sedated
reserve list
awaiting the call to fight
so he along with 20 or so friends banded
together to deliver humanitarian aid to
harkiv and other hard-hit regions
even paying for gas and supplies out of
their own pocket
there he meets two families eager to
remove their children from the war zone
iguenia coslova and her two daughters
spent 10 days underground in a bomb
shelter before finally finding a ride
out of the city
cheers
m
[Music]
now they head west uncertain of what
lies ahead for them among many
ukrainians there's a sense of
bewilderment
while many thought a conflict with
russia could indeed happen
in harkiv the reality is far worse than
anything they could have imagined
[Music]
home of diripra has largely been spared
before the war he worked as a lawyer and
had his hands full with two young boys
and a newborn daughter
when the invasion began his wife and
kids went to stay with relatives near
the hungarian border
for him though staying behind was never
a question
yesterday
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
she just can't stay
without moving for a minute that's the
house where we are living after a
13-hour drive alexi and his family have
now made it safely to kremenchuk in
central ukraine
it's really beautiful sunset here
how are you doing young lady
are you fine
meanwhile in harkiv the nightly shelling
has intensified
russian forces continue to bombard
civilian areas of the city
leaving emergency crews scrambling to
put out the flames
despite the devastation alexis says
ukrainians remain confident they will
win this war and when they do he'll be
returning home to rebuild
almost everybody in ukraine i believe
more than 98 percent of people
united in one community in one family
that's how it looks right now that's how
it feels right now yeah a lot of people
scared really scared the the things that
makes us scared and afraid they make us
powerful and more united